hello and welcome to the introductory
lesson of the android applications
development course for beginners offered
by simply learn in this lesson you will
get an overview of the course why
android with the highest market share
android is the dominant mobile operating
system today it's running on countless
models of smartphones tablets and other
devices what's even more important is
the fact that the whole android
ecosystem underwent many improvements we
got new gadgets like smart watches new
software like gradle android studio and
android's new operating system
which is the 6.0 marshmallow
there are several advantages
let me tell you the key advantages in
learning to develop applications for
android firstly market share android
absolutely dominated the number of
smartphones shipped worldwide in the
first three months of 2015 with 78
market share android studio is an ide
designed and developed specifically for
android app development it is blazingly
fast and efficient and you can set up a
new android project for different types
of android apps within seconds also
applications deployed to the google play
store are available for download by
users within a few hours compared to a
few weeks for apple's app store android
developers are more because of high
number of users in android operating
system
many companies are investing huge money
on android application development that
is where open access and open source
principles have shown their true
potentials
what is this course all about
this course is a collection of resources
that cover tools and principles for
designing and building android apps it
also includes many advanced topics like
material design
maps location services using sensors and
app distribution after completion of the
course you will be able to create apps
according to your imagination
interesting facts about this android app
development course
android was first designed for cameras
later it was implemented for mobile
phones
when compared with other operating
systems
the android operating system has been
updated an incredible number of times
resulting in a web-based service
which is remarkably different than the
original version of this mobile
operating system
it has unlocked a number of new parts
android studio is now the default
integrated development environment ide
in short supported by google to develop
android applications
we will learn how to install the android
sdk and android studio
which provide an essential environment
to build an android application and
fundamentals like activities fragments
and ui controls to name a few
android architecture has four layers
each layer has its own set of libraries
and we will be talking in brief on each
layer
we will also clarify the dynamics to
understand the core libraries and talk
more about the android operating system
for app development
we will explore the building blocks of
android application like activity
services content providers broadcast
receiver and intents
we will go through the best practices
do's and don'ts while developing android
application to publish on your play
store how did android application
development evolve smartphones have
revolutionized the way we create and
consume information today people can
barely recall life before mobile apps
nowadays smartphones have changed our
lives and how
from checking the weather the minute you
wake up
to finding a recipe for pot roast from
getting a doctor on demand to playing a
game while waiting for the bus
apps have become a way of life
be it a washing machine or a quadcopter
android has become integral to everyday
living
in more ways than you can count
over 1 billion android devices have been
activated and ruling the smartphone
market is
android who enjoys an 85 percent market
share
need we say more
establishing the need of the
application's development
most people like to use android
technology in their smartphones because
of its obvious advantages
with its unbelievable popularity
developers will certainly want to get
into android application development to
a greater extent and get the best from
the booming app industry in case you're
new to this field and want to know how
you can be a part of this app revolution
then this is the course for creating a
winning app i will share a few of the
key advantages of android application
development the biggest advantage of
android is that
it is an open source integrated software
platform
it decreases the developmental phase
and offers simple to apply development
tools
android has encouraged innovation among
the developers to come up with new
applications to help sustain in a highly
competitive market its association with
google has made it powerful with google
maps and google voice apps
in today's business context with android
available as an open platform
customization has become far less
expensive than other platforms
market trends and predictions for
android apps
google's android has grown immensely
from october 2003 when ruben miner sears
and white
started android inc in california
the popularity of android did not come
about in a day
android developers braved buggy ides
os fragmentation slow emulators and
boring user interface to what it is
today
linux based open source android has
boosted the fast growing smartphone
market build over it released the first
version on the htc dream phone in 2008
it took several iterations over the
years to get it to what it is today
in the last couple of years the android
ecosystem has seen many improvements in
terms of new software hardware and
operating system
what next asks google the developers the
makers of devices
now that the operating system is stable
where do we go from here
android which was started with
smartphones is now in smart watches tvs
and cars
it has proven that it can be run on
every gadget which has a small
microprocessor
as the trend continues the number of
apps available in the google play store
crossed 1.6 million as per july 2015
stats which clearly shows its market
penetration what is the objective of
this course for android applications
development course for beginners
this course is intended for people who
want to create native applications on
android it is necessary that you have a
good understanding of java before
getting started on this path if you
don't know java please consider taking
this introductory java essentials course
from simplylearn here is the course
breakdown you have 10 lessons
lesson 1
will be an introduction to android
development in which you will learn how
to set up the environment and understand
the architecture of android
lesson 2 is more about android user
interfaces activities and controls
you will be able to use controls add
validation and a few basic programming
skills to develop an android user
interface
lesson 3 is all about the layouts and
controls
how you order the layouts
android canvas and have you use android
studio to create a layout and control
lesson 4 will take you to android list
view and sqlite
have to fetch data and then put it
across to list view
and have to obtain the data from list
view and put it on escalate lesson 5 is
all about services
services are those which run in the
background if you have a task which
takes a lot of time the best practice is
to do it in the background or ui at the
end of this lesson you will learn to
manage and effectively use the services
lesson 6 talks about content providers
content providers are a set of methods
or a set of classes of a small library
which android offers a content source
can be a database your rss readers or
even your web service
lesson 7 is on user interface here
the user interface will use fragments
you will learn how to build a time
picker user interface
which can work on both mobile
applications and tablets lesson 8 is
about location and sensors this lesson
will be on how to get location on your
mobile phone and understand all the
different sensors you have on the
android phone to make the best use of
these sensors lesson 9 is all the fun
stuff about multimedia here you will
learn how to record a video audio and
have to use the camera to take a picture
or to record a video
we will go through a small multimedia
demo and explain the fundamentals of how
to build an application for android
multimedia applications
lesson 10 will introduce you to google
play
you will know what it is all about and
get to know the checklist required for
your application to be hosted on google
play you'll have lots of demos most of
them will be simple some of them will be
travel world demos this concludes the
course introduction the next lesson is
introduction to android development
wishing you all the best for this course
happy learning